This same sky trend.
Technologies for linear synchronis
motors and the maglev,
uh,
are being applied to a wind
technologies.
What we're doing with our partner,
one cycle control and power conversion.
There's a couple aspects of this.
We are number one,
we're building a unit here in Irvine to
go up in palm springs to replace a 1980s
Norwegian,
a 58 foot diameter,
windmill,
65 kilowatts.
This should be going up in a couple of
weeks and we'll have to test it for a
couple months and then there's going to
be several hundred if they liked the
data they see.
In other words,
we do all this math and physics,
but now you've got to build stuff and
prove it.
So that's what we're doing.
So this technology,
we will eliminate the gearboxes where
you have a direct drive system.
40% of the lifetime costs of windmills
is the gearboxes they wear out.
The same reason on skytrain,
you don't want gearboxes and tires,
things wear out.
The other aspect is the power
conversion.
We can take low,
low speeds and high high speeds and
supply to the utility.
Southern California Edison.
In this instance,
proper frequency electric and was,
if all your s frequency is 60 cycle,
maybe they can accept between 50 and 70
while if they're great,
greatest mean,
pulled down to say 59.3 cycles a second,
guess what?
We're going to deliver 59.3 and this is
the one cycle control power technology.
What this enables is we can gather
energy at very low speeds and higher
speeds up to the limitations where you
have a good structural safety factor on
the props.
We sidebuy sea side the geared type
system compared to our system.
In a year,
we should be able to sell about double
the energy to southern California
Anderson on the same wind profile on the
same hill.
This is going to be pretty hot.
We're getting a lot of interest in
financial interest in this technology
and it really actually gets better when
we started talking three or five
megawatt wind mills,
the big ones,
and there's even 10 megawatt wind mills
up,
uh,
being designed not to.
Yeah.